Jennifer we have a very special guest in
studio we know we like to make fun of
them but what can I say Rex is the man
that's right we have rack Singh field in
studio with Alejandra right now thank
you guys of course without him none of
this would be possible so as always
Thank You Rex for thank you making it
happen
how have you enjoyed the tournament so
far oh my goodness it's this is amazing
him so many decisive games you know I
said last night I think I said to Yasser
at dinner we have a new slogan here
women's get women get things done dr.
Jeanne sink Phil just gave me some key
stats that he wanted me to read that she
wanted me to read over the air dr.
Jeanne Singh field said the scene field
cop that's your namesake in 2018 80% of
the games were drawn and in 2019 83% in
her tournament the Karen Scott wait a
minute drum roll please
only 44% in 2019 and so far 40 percent
in 2020 what's wrong
mm-hmm well I'm sure if you do a t-test
on that you will find these differences
are significant the first of all I want
to acknowledge commend and thank the
greatest broadcast team any sport in the
world
absolutely not just in the world in the
entire galaxy I have scoured the galaxy
and nobody is as good as you people
that's we're wonderful thank you so much
makes it easy with the player especially
the ones we got here guys such fun games
we've been able to witness or accent you
a little bit jealous about this
tournament what do you think that also
many draws in this thing field Cobb
that's an issue you know it but it's not
gonna change we know how it works at
that highest level exactly well I don't
know directing we have ideas right you
guys could explain who was it you were
yeah somebody saved me last night that
at that top level these guys just will
not take any risk they take less risk
for certain we've seen a lot of risk
being taking some guys I mean like check
out the curse I'll go Nina again no this
tournament right
the women they'll take risk to win right
they'll go after it but it seems like in
the Sinquefield Cup at that higher level
they just don't do it seems like the
punishment
margin is so high some people like to
play it safe and sometimes we gotta
force them a little bit right I carry
the game yeah I guess you know I got a
tolerate that stuff yeah well so I we
have here as we were extracting the draw
between religion and hierarchy Drona
Valley definitely a game that was
important for the standings you in June
trying to put as much pressure as she
could but Hartke very solid player
herself so right so you've been a big
supporter of women's chess for a long
time how does it feel to finally see
like a great event like this in the
United States oh I think this is this is
just fabulous and I think I kind of hope
I don't get in trouble for saying this
next year we have to raise the price fun
Wow you know and keep raising it I think
this is incredibly good for it's
exciting for chess around the world it's
especially exciting for women and girls
and I hope this motivates a lot of them
to take up and to stay in chess and I
think it will - no I have to agree this
determines specifically of course we
have the US Women's Championship us one
of our name sakes
right here in the club but in the
continent it just seemed like we were
lacking a professional top-level women's
event right no this is this is the top
this is certainly stronger than the US
Women's Championship yes there's a
wonderful event if anybody can think of
something better I'm all for it how we
top this we've enjoyed the format
tremendously the players are giving us
great fight I think we're approaching
time pressure guys maybe right is there
any big updates that we don't want to
miss any handshakes going on right well
what's that let's update that Chrissy
good game guys we can bring Rex into the
analysis actually is star student here
for Jennifer Shahadah
showing off her talents as a chess coach
Rex what can you show us rook takes
Knight well Carissa actually just played
a superstar move she went after Queen a7
check King to c8 and she's recognizing
look she's crashing through on the Queen
site she's got one major issue to deal
with this rook coming to d1 she found
this very very nice move rook a to 2a
calmly defending referred shrank and
saying to Valentina our defending
champion go ahead and defend your night
if the Night Moves careful this jack and
I'm gonna be picking up this pawn and we
think that Karissa who started so badly
oh and four it's gonna go back-to-back
wins that's right and one last question
for you regarding that Rex I mean we
have two Americans in this tournament
Irina crash Chrissy yet I know it's
particularly important to you to develop
chess in the United States and in st.
Louis I thank you for the the grant that
you and the st. Louis Chess Club are
partnering with us and us chess what do
you think it means to players like
Carissa and I arena to get to play with
the top players in the world right yeah
I think it's very important for them and
Irina in particular and everybody knows
you know a big supporter of Irina and I
hope she wins ten women's championships
only three to go
only three to go Bobby Fischer got eight
she has seven and Bobby Fischer said
winning eight US Championships was a
greater achievement than being world
champion and it's gonna be tough for
Irina it gets harder every year it's
probably the single is chess but I
remember when the u.s. women's just came
to the club and Irina I thought that
were so far ahead in the rating list of
everybody right everybody right now look
at charissa she's a number two player in
the country by rating and she's a kid
she liked better
I know they just can't trust these kids
these days everything you do here thank
you something club guys we're in time
pressure do we do just finish you will
be joining us shortly here on the show
exactly thank you Rick's always always a
pleasure indeed and wearing the same
color as the world champion today so
well coordinated Rex
seriously though they the u.s.
championship does Alejandra keep getting
stronger and so is Krista India